muito boa tarde a todos
eu sou a 2 eu só dei costa e vou começar
por dizer que eu sou angolana
mas quando eu digo isso para qualquer
pessoa quando ela apresenta assim pra
qualquer estrangeiro é essa imagem que
eles têm
a primeira coisa mas não é só para os
estrangeiros não é só deixar de fora os
estrangeiros aqui para os angolanos
continuam densas quantos não há nesses
mesmos considerados privilegiados nunca
suspeitaram para fora dos muros muitos
muitos aqui incluindo e não são só os
rolandenses provincianos extermo usado
por alguns luandenses para descrever não
luandenses e aceites por não dance é uma
vez foi interpelada por um polícia no
bengo nosso vizinho ele olhou pra mim
sinceramente perguntou porque como subia
como eu estava vendo as fora de angola e
brasil alguns segundos para perceber se
ele durante ou não espera aí porque a 10
para os provincianos angola é luanda e
eu cresci numa sociedade numa geração
que tenha muito mais valor muito mais
prestígio e para fora portugal áfrica do
sul
eu fui pra férias na américa do que
conhecer os restantes 98 por cento do
território nacional
sim porque um golo antes das passarelas
a 0,2 por cento
conhecer um país que eu chamo de popular
completamente esquizofrênico porque eu
nunca vi nenhum sítio no mundo que no
mesmo território nacional vocês
encontram de florestas tropicais há
desertos e planícies vastas montanhas
mais histórias de praias infinitas a
rios gigantescos os rios água base da
vida uma das riquezas mais valorizadas
de angola que alimenta outros países
também
por isso quando me chamaram pra ele
descobrir o majestoso okavango
era e nem sequer sabia o cavalo na
assembléia quando me disseram vamos
pelas matas de angola descobriram na
açúcar vaga primeiro tive que o google
saber onde é que nós vamos exatamente
mas lá descobrir maior bacia não
explorada do mundo não explorada
digo que não tem prédios nem
desmatamento etc portanto não explorado
em termos científicos e assim e resolvi
juntar numa equipa do mês da national
geographic para diluir um bocadinho a
testosterona dar um toque eo feminino a
equipa
e então fomos a descoberta desse mítico
nascente do okavango e entramos em
estradas mim nada sem frustradas que não
existiam que nós fizemos em florestas
mil ambos são erradas que ninguém
conhecia seu apontavam naquela direção
naquela direção até que abriu se uma
visão e sempre que eu volto como se vê a
mesma emoção a nascente do rio kuito
nessa nascente a lagoa do rio circuito
tão antigo
os cientistas e geólogos foram para não
fazem a mínima ideia como é que se
formou não fazem não sabem como é
conseguir constituir uma lagoa tão
preciosa e não durar muito tempo assim
que chegamos estamos todos entusiasmados
e resolvemos partir logo para o nosso
método de trabalho que é a canoa chamar
por objetivo era armar o sistema todo
durante 80 dias
estávamos muito enganados mas por outro
lado vemos nas canoas
logo nos primeiros dias nós descobrimos
que o rio kuito nós chamamos mãe curto
nós que tivemos nessa expedição nós
chamamos a mãe muito porque o rio kuito
ensino estão ensinando as lições que são
nossas mães nos ensina não é daquelas
mães que o passo a mão na cabeça na rua
é daquelas mães que fazem soar fazem a
lacrimejar fazendários o teu sangue para
aprender as melhores lições da vida é a
primeira lição que nós aprendemos foi
conta sempre com o inesperado porque a
lagoa não tinha saída portanto não tinha
como
acho que nós passarem para além do rio
então durante duas semanas nós tivemos
o chá canoas de 500 quilos ao longo do
vale do rio preto
pois não foi divertido a pessoas que
tenham batimento cardíaco dos 192 por
média era de que considera ter um ataque
cardíaco mas não para andar no calor
basicamente ea segunda eleição depois
disso tudo depois de 22 semanas de
sofrimento foi que depois da tempestade
vem a bonança
o rio abriu se e é o rio não tem cura
uns dizem que é ver todos dizem que
turquesa é uma cor tão límpida tão linda
eu nunca tinha visto nada assim a base
branca da areia filtrada pela areia do
kalahari quando eu voltei pra luanda
durante duas semanas já voltara hábito
arma a água industrializada que vende no
supermercado porque essa água sabe a
pureza e assim foi o cavalo abrindo se
para nós mostrar as suas paisagens as
maravilhas da gola como costumam dizer e
mostrou que essas questões valem a pena
não é só sofrimento falou mais do que
isso mas nós continuamos a nossa viagem
a terceira lição da vida tem curvas e
contra curvas e nós aprendemos isso nós
aprendemos isso para quando for pra
fazer um zoom quilômetros em linha reta
nós temos que fazer quatro quilômetros
no rio rir assim confuso não sabia a
senha para norte para sul
fazia quatro pontos cada imagem no mesmo
quilômetro e nós só temos que acompanhar
seguir as coisas da vida adaptarmo nos a
isso quando descobrimos como fazer isso
lá vem a mãe clinton e mostrou nos que
há sempre que respeitar os donos da casa
é uma lição que todas as mais em toda
angola tal não adianta chegar a um sítio
e pensar na nós aqui já descobrir não os
guardiões do rio ensinar anos isso
porque não respeitaram os donos da casa
se você já tem hora que eu acho que um
desses levanta canoa como uma boneca de
trapos e ficam coisas assim a rua no ar
como foi o que aconteceu conosco pessoas
no rio e hipopótamos até hoje voltamos
ficam assustados da maneira que nós vôo
da manhã quando um deles pornôs a
aprovar e assim foi a viagem 6 de
batalhas e de conquistas e aprendemos
imenso até chegar ao derradeiro troféu
aquilo que faz abrir os olhos dos
contratos pelos contrastes com a
paisagem de angola que o delta do
okavango uma patrimônio natural da
unesco como a melhor população de
elefantes africanos com mais 200 mil
indivíduos com maior número de leões
africanos mais de 2 mil indivíduos uma
biodiversidade tão estável num
ecossistema tão prestigiado renda ao
governo mostrou nessa parte do mundo
gosta de saber venda o governo de
botsuana mais de 400 bilhões de dólares
por ano só com turismo mas ainda não tem
nada
trinta por cento é deserto literalmente
deserto o delta do okavango é a riqueza
do botsuana e mais do que isso o
botsuana fornece momentos únicos com
alguns dos animais mais perigosos
fantásticos mais perigosas do mundo
mas para um momento como este pois as
mulheres coisas na vida não são de graça
num momento como esse fomos ameaçados
por elefantes fomos virá do chá baixo
purys botamos fomos atacados por aviões
fomos assustados por leopardos babuínos
criam lutar conosco as cobras com uma
cobra ea mulher quando estava a tomar
banho porque depois eu descobri que
afinal estava embaixo estava a mulher o
buraco dela não sabia e assim
sucessivamente
os melhores momentos não são de graça
em momentos como esse que proporciona
uma viagem tão dura a cápsula originar
eu vou fazer aqui outra vez e chegamos
ao fim da viagem
entre aumente no meio do nada água
decidiu parar de circular civil
simplesmente o lago raúl é o sítio mais
mal cheiroso que eu já vi em toda a
minha vida e então esse nome que não é o
ponto final ou algum dos oradores que
disso que a gente queria ir até o
horizonte não é um horizonte o caminho
para chegar horizonte que a pessoa
aprenda que a pessoa vê é isso que
importa
123 dias quatro meses um terço do ano
arrumar oito horas por dia são das armas
a puxar os canais têm 500 quilos
não estávamos a pixar estávamos a
empurrar por com os rápidos não dá pra
passar pra quê porque muita gente
pergunta por que uma mulher uma musa bia
como eu vai fazer isso eu até sou
holandês tem tudo aqui tem um emprego o
que a primeira coisa sabia de felicidade
eu tive o privilégio de ir a mostrar
numa das áreas menos conhecidas da
região da bacia do okavango angola é uma
das áreas mais remotas havia vilas que
não viam visitante há 40 anos e nós
encontramos quatro novas espécies de
peixe três novas espécies de aranhas
quatro novas espécies de plantas seis
novas espécies de répteis a confirmação
comprovada que existem mabecos no
planalto de angola uma coisa todos os
especialistas sempre dúvidas sempre
disseram que nunca existe e nós temos
todos os mamíferos ainda existentes
muitos pensam que não estão extintos não
adianta não não
eles existem só quem populações tão
instáveis e com tanta pressão humana que
se escondem que prefere retirar a sua
presença para poderem sobreviver e é
isso que nós temos que mudar e nós temos
que mudar a nossa visão de conservação
nós temos que alterar esse conceito
conservacionista conservação é assinar
um papel tem o parque acabou não temos
que pensar para além disso nós temos
pensar qual é a necessidade desses
animais a maior parte vamos falar dele
fácil do mundo gosta dele fácil assim
fios sem fãs são migratórias eles não
sabem o que são fronteiras seja não
precisam de passaporte eles quiserem por
um lado vamos querer voltar não tem água
ali
bora e é isso que nós precisamos do
frete conservação tem que ser
transplantation nos pode limitar um
animal porque significa que angola e
namíbia então aquela pedra tv no limite
não pode ser aquela pedra mole mas não
pensam assim
os animais fazem aquilo que estão
destinadas a fazer sempre a bola sempre
proporciona e pra ver conservação nós
temos que aprender com países com mais
experiência mas também convencer de que
é isso que nós precisamos coordenadores
migratórias ter a possibilidade de dar
lhes essa liberdade que eles tiveram
antes de nós chegamos respeitar os donos
do casa nós temos que respeitar quem
aqui estava antes de nós chegamos e
vamos ter isto aqui animais que nós
perdemos o que estão escondidos afluírem
novamente a encherem as nossas paisagens
aqueles predadores que todo mundo tem
medo a voltarem a imergir nós ainda
temos só precisam de ter a coragem de
voltar à possível
é isso que nós precisamos mas pra isso é
preciso também convencer que aqueles que
eles comandam o que é isso que nós
precisamos agora está na moda ao turismo
isso é uma boa maneira de fazer ver o
dinheiro já não está aqui nos prédios do
dinheiro ale de 400 bilhões de dólares
que eles procuram tallin
mas para além disso uma coisa que todo
mundo e não são só os governadores têm
que aprender isso não aprendemos com e
fielmente conhece
não adianta não adianta estamos a pôr
planos concebidas por nós que nunca
vivemos naquela área para pessoas que
vivem lá há décadas para pessoas que
viram aquilo a mudar pra pessoas que
conseguem melhor do que qualquer
cientista de modelagem prever o que
poderá acontecer caso se mudem isso caso
muda aquilo para pessoas que não têm
alternativas de vida
não adianta para pessoas que magoamos
ambiente não pura prazer mas por
necessidade que essa cidade tornou-se
triste porque eles sabem o que estão a
fazer o que eles vão fazer mais
eles precisam fazer isso para sobreviver
portanto não é para serem julgados não é
pra dizer tudo tem que parar de caçá
educação precisam e vão passar fome
se eles não passarem nunca fala das suas
na beira da estrada estou a falar de
pessoas que não vêem visitantes há 40
anos e se nós não tivermos essa
consciência realidade como esta nunca
vão deixar de existir este leopardo foi
abatido nas margens do rio com a naval
em março por angulares e foi vendido por
25 mil coisas para um sambinha ano o
sami a vender por 50 mil dólares é o
americano e assim sucessivamente
este animal para quem não sabe
comparando com o delta do botsuana vale
2 milhões de dólares por ano em turismo
a minha primeira memória com muita gente
aqui a guerra de 92 minha primeira
memória o som de um macaco 47 vamos
dizer não existe nada mais terrível do
que ouvir isso a noite numa tenda a ser
difícil pra ele absolutamente nada e não
foi contador não por um falsificador
o vento eo animal queria fazer como os
outros
talvez esse tipo de consciência que nós
temos que mudar ao longo da bacia falar
do conhecimento por meio do conhecimento
natural 90 com pressa nela
estamos a formar a pessoa nem revelam
isso tem feito embora soa ficar na tenda
e não podia fazer absolutamente nada nem
poderia lado julinho vai mudar que vai
acordar para uma visão dessa da lágrima
nos olhos a quem batalhou tanto para
poder conhecer este lugar é um lugar
lindo da imagem
só mudando isso viesse a paisagem é
bonita linda
vocês vêem uma cascata que ninguém
conhecia os locais chamando a cascata
nem sequer tem nome
os governadores não sabiam que existia
agora imaginem que essa cascata não
sofreu a queimadense ano está toda verde
que as áreas de estoque o cheiro está
tudo bonitinho agora imagina que todos
os animais não foram alcançados nessa
zona
então todos ali acorreram imaginam esse
cenário
agora imagina quando vocês vão alguém eu
sou angolana em cenário que eles vêem o
imaginário não sou que está na
fotografia e é isso que eu quero chegar
alguém dizer eu sou angular não esquece
o guarda irlandesa eu sou angolana
esquece o anda o futuro está no resto do
país o futuro está no cavalo e só pra
quem tem experiências como essa percebe
que quem só conhecia ainda não sabe o
que é o céu também aqui que são estrelas
que não sabem o que é ter o céu a
consumir nos ficar tempo hipnotizada não
consegue pensar em absolutamente mais
nada quando falando no mato e pensão com
uma terceirense ozu na rua até
barulhento golfo quando voltei pra casa
quando os envolvidos fazer aquele
zumbido dos é sempre meu vídeo estava no
meu quarto por com mato tem é uma
solidão acompanhada dos insetos pássaros
dos animais ouvir os leões a fugirem à
noite e votamos a reclamarem é estar num
sítio e pertencer ser mais do que o ser
humano moderno e sentir todos todos os
sentidos que o homem tem
funcionarem ao mesmo tempo é vice anta é
viciante olhar para um sítio mas não tá
sua vez estava cheia do quase consegue
sentir a terra está naquele lugar
consegue sentir que a linha vai fazer só
para direita se você acha que da silva
prates vai para trás se o jacaré que
está ao lado da tua canon aqui é maior
que atua canoa vai decidir a coberta ou
não é ter essa ligação é sentir o que
ser humano realmente é lá no fundo é que
nós pretendemos que fazemos parte desse
sistema é pertencer e as novas gerações
que nós temos que ensinar que não é ter
qualquer um pode ter qualquer um pode
fazer para ter um carro uma casa é sede
é que nós queremos ser
onde é que nós queremos estar onde é que
a casa e só sendo e só pertencendo é que
nós podemos fazer
por que abraçar causas ali e assinar só
tem que sentir na pele o que quero e
aumento fazer da vida ter essa paixão
portanto quando digo que sou angolana é
isso que eu vejo eu sou lá eu sou do
okavango eu sou muito mais do que o
andrés
agora em minha apresentação acabou aqui
em gaza